thank you very much for coming to our
talk this is scaling data and AI to
increase player engagement and
satisfaction at Square Enix
I'm Sam weeks from Google cloud and with
me today we have from your left John
house
senior digital engineering manager
Square Enix tatsway Yoshida director of
data science Square Enix and deadly AIML
specialist Google Cloud
so we're all from London or flew in over
the weekend thanks very much for for
having us
okay this is what we're going to go
through today first of all John is going
to talk about single game review which
is the global data platform that Square
Enix have built
then that's where I will talk about some
of the new data science use cases that
he's built on top of single game review
especially those that focus on player
engagement and player satisfaction
and then lastly Deb will talk to us
about where we want to take this in the
future in terms of operationalizing some
of these use cases on Google Cloud
the journey with Square Enix and Google
cloud has been a successful one and a
fairly long one it started back in 2017
actually with single game review which
John will talk about in a minute we
moved over to Google Cloud to deal with
uh scalability issues that they had
on-prem and since then there have been
many milestones and improvements and
additional
workloads as well coming to Google Cloud
including the platform services that
power their games and the first party
identity system to manage their players
in the player's life cycle
we call out a previous talk actually at
GDC in 2019 which was also on single
game review but spoke more about the
foundations of single game View and the
initial use cases and today we're gonna
um
uh sort of talk a bit more about what
we've been doing in more recent times
uh it's a real pleasure to be sharing
the stage with Square Enix
um John and Tatsu are both leaders in
their fields prospective fields and
they're really pushing the boundary on
what's possible with data when utilized
in the right way
so the last thing I want to say before
passing on is we actually think that now
is a really interesting time to be
talking about data especially first
party data I think historically we would
leverage cookies and third-party data
and use marketing agencies a lot to do
that and that ended up meaning that we
sort of
outsourced a lot of the player
relationship that we would have to these
marketing agencies
um now cookies are kind of going away
that forces us to maybe think a little
bit differently and sort of take back
um ownership of the player relationship
which is probably a good thing but it
does mean that there's a growing need
for in-house data capabilities and data
platforms that can scale globally and
provide us real-time insights and
real-time decision making
and we at Google think Google cloud is
the data analytics platform for live
service games
um if you go to any of the other Google
Cloud talks
um this week you'll hear more about that
and I'd encourage you to do so but for
now it's just great that we can stand
with a brand as well known and
well-loved as query next and they can
talk directly about their own
experiences
so with that I will pass over to John
and he'll talk us through single game
review thank you John
thanks very much Sam it's a pleasure to
be here so I'm John head of data
engineering here at Square Enix I've
been in technology across news and games
for 16 years 11 of which have been at
Square where over the last five years I
have headed up the data engineering team
and I'm interested in games
reliable processing of data and
obligatory cat picture my cat Clio
it was either a picture of Cleo or me I
think I made the right choice
so as Sam mentioned we've been working
with Google Cloud on SG for a number of
years I'm going to do a bit of a recap
on that
um and then
basically move on to how we've extended
that in more recent times before handing
over to tattoo
so why Google Cloud we felt there was a
very strong networking infrastructure
underpinning the cloud services which
met our data processing needs allowing
us to really collect data at a vast
scale we really appreciated the
engineering-led culture of Google cloud
and the team had a really embedded feel
within the teams on our side
and
the overall platform had a very nice
uniform feel
giving you all the options you needed to
deploy your services but not
overloading you with stuff you really
didn't need to worry about
and of course off the shelf it has
bigquery which met the SQL needs of the
analytics team out of the box
our requirements for moving off our old
on-prem system were that we wanted to be
able to capture data at any scale
process it in near Real Time store it
at a well
vast level in our centralized data store
build data warehousing
layers on top of that and make it
available to consume within the business
in bi and advanced analytics processes
we of course
have a requirement to our fans to
handle their data securely and safely so
we wanted to be able to perform
filtering of that data
within our data processing pipelines
ensuring we didn't recapture anything we
didn't want to and
in our view layers not expose that data
unnecessarily and then be able to
process that and remove that from our
data Stores
um as needed
the MVP architecture we came up with
generally follows the Google reference
architecture for data streaming and data
processing so from our games we would be
able to collect that into Cloud Pub sub
and GCS where we couldn't Implement
streaming at the time we then process
that with data flow
batch and streaming as necessary before
storing that within
bigquery and then consuming that in
Lookout and power bi in dataflow we
offer a number of features which really
complement our game development Studios
we can do things like validate and store
rejected events if any come in and allow
them to
take a look at them and fix any issues
we can backup events as required we can
do the aforementioned Pi filtering and
we can dynamically migrate the schemas
in bigquery if anything changes
in real time now this is
really valuable to the
um Studios and we found
that unfortunately there were a few
bottlenecks within our initial Pipelines
we worked very closely with the Google
Cloud support team to come up with
techniques to remedy that
so we moved from insert IDs offloading
the deduplication that they would have
otherwise offered to separate processors
Downstream we moved our rate limit to a
volume limit
and we made we made a few tweaks to some
of the parameters afforded to us in data
flow things like batch parallelism
streaming keys that kind of thing which
allowed us to ensure that we could meet
our self-imposed million events a second
per pipeline
albeit with a bit of a trade-off at
lower scaling
now
as I mentioned there were a few
architectural changes the core a
critical path of the data remains
broadly the same but we split out our
streaming pipeline into two halves
allowing us to scale them independently
and use
different workers more suited to the
tasks that they performed
otherwise
the architecture remained broadly the
same but we were able to have a
consistent sub 2 second ish end-to-end
time from when data hit our Pub Sub in
endpoints
to it being inserted and into bigquery
and being made available to the business
implementing these features also allowed
us to add new data sources to our data
Lake these include web events
user account information social data CRM
sales and a few others
which allowed us to activate the data
differently with our partners in
advertising and more importantly
the data science team
our current environment consists of
using Google collab notebooks for
code sharing for a python and SQL
scripts before
when productionizing them via our gitlab
cicd environment
and offloading the orchestration onto
Google Cloud composer and having the
main bulk of the workloads running in
gke
now we are also looking at
potentially moving those workloads into
vertex AI platform
but to talk you through that and the
data science use cases I will hand you
over to tatsuo Yoshida our director of
data science
[Applause]
okay next okay so I'm nice to meet you
hi I'm director of data science in
analysis and insight Department
I'll be watching these Phoenix for
around 6 years and previously working
advertising agency
we have data science team we built a
team in 2020 so it's relatively new team
and in 2022 we made machine learning
pipeline which gave us the power to
deploy machine learning model into
production and as you can see we are
capturing the team it's only by the way
it's not my dog
so today I want to talk to you about how
is data science for CRM customer
relationship management
so these are the business challenges we
are facing like when we send email we
want to make sure that the email we send
is relevant
second point is that we don't
necessarily want to measure email only
by opens or clicks because what we
really want is to increase engagement
and third point is that when you do a b
testing it many times gets complicated
especially in a company like screenix
because we have offices in Japan U.S and
UK
totally different time zone 3D
so that's why we have this machine
learning based email solution
machine learning model send the email
then we measure in-game data and this
in-game engagement data is going to fade
back to machine learning model and this
feedback loop makes sure that the email
we send is relevant
is tailored messaging for Final Fantasy
14.
Final Fantasy 14 as you may know is an
online title it's been running for 10
years we have in total 27 million
players
so Final Fantasy 14 can be played in so
many different ways
it's a role playing game so you progress
story or you fight against enemies but
that's not a business in the game can
offer
um you can the game offers non-battle
content like crafting or gathering or it
has some social aspects like housing or
free company
so the game can be played in so many
different ways so it's really important
for us to understand how player play
this game
the three we are currently using machine
learning model to segment user into five
different groups
low engagement PBE pressure
PVP player and high engagement
so we have this model and then the
question is how do we use this
we have the engagement campaign called
free login campaign
what this is that we are welcome in user
who stop playing the game to come back
to the game
and in the email we are announcing this
free domain champagne to user we pick
content which suits each used as play
style
and this result in more people
participating in free robbing campaign
and the most importantly is that we see
more people actually engaging in-game
content that's really good
then the second use case is automated
baby testing cycle for life history cars
it's a single player adventure game
so you are currently sending email
automatically to those who stop playing
the game and we are encouraging them to
come back to the game and continue
playing the game
and before I talk about automation I
want to talk about what is a b testing
um it's really simple but you test a few
things and to see which works best
that's it really
but in reality it can be really really
complex where it's horrible presentation
I know
um the first thing you need to do is
that you create user group okay this is
a blue predictive pattern a this is a
group pattern B C D and if you make any
mistake then it could result in really
bad like
sending the same email twice to the same
user or being there we end up sending
email without any subject line
it's horrible
yeah then after we send emails um well
we want to know how it went so we join
in-game data and email data and we we
end up writing hundreds of secret code
and it's really difficult to debug
because it's full of joins
and then we compare performance and if
you only have pattern a and pattern B
it's kind of simple but if you have so
many patterns and we sometimes end up
doing multivariate testing it's another
topic for data science and 3D
and well then we do
level the stakeholders in so many
different time zones
and the biggest issue here is a step two
to step four needs to be completed you
need such short time it's really tough
but
now we have this automated cycle and
I've explained a lot in the previous
page and everything is automated now
and this is actually use case so going
back to life history class case we
prepare three subject line and we
provide those to machine learning models
of course machine learning model does
not know as a beginning which workspace
so it just choose this service line
randomly from those three choices and
then after that machine learning model
starts realizing okay pattern B seems to
be working so it includes the pattern B
more and more so it's really amazing
that it's as I said it's automated and
if you do this in money away it's kind
of horrible yes
yeah and also this machine learning
automation is making everyone happy this
made our life much easier really because
as I said we had manual process and it
was really difficult to maintain
especially especially during holiday
seasons well simply because everyone is
on holiday
and also you know manual reporting with
um different stakeholders in different
time zones
if you do this once and twice then
that's fine but if you do this in a
regular way then it's kind of complex
and difficult
and also this is making our fans happy
so now customer receive less email under
emails they received is relevant to what
they want
and we see people
um coming back to the game continue
playing the game and finish the game and
go to the next game so we are making
fans happy
so the summary of single game review
which is screen existing has solution is
that we have all the data in one place
and with this we can provide reports to
across to the entire organization
and we provide data to game studio so
the studio can make better game and as
I've explained and we are improving
funds engagement
and also thanks to the engineer team and
we get data in real time in a reliable
fashion and also its gdpr compliant
and next step for data science is that
so far so good I guess and however the
kind situation is that the more model we
create
the more mode we need to Monitor and
maintain and it's getting really complex
so that's why we are kind of exploring
vertex AI which is gcp managed machine
learning solution this should make our
life much easier and for details I'll
hand over to Deb
thank you
nice thank you very much tatsuo hi
everyone I'm Deb Lee I get to work with
this amazing team so I'm from Google
cloud and I work very closely in the
data analytics and AI machine learning
space uh so I'm gonna step back a little
bit and actually you know put a bit of
perspective around just companies that
are trying to scale their AI workloads
uh and just to really call it the fact
that you know seeing success with
deploying these types of models and be
able to do that in a real-time fashion
should not be understated in terms of
the difficulty that surrounds these
types of processes and that even now
only like 36 of data science pocs
actually even tend to make it into
production and that could be for a
variety of reasons so maybe it the
business teams have difficulty actually
identifying which use cases are going to
be the highest value for them uh maybe
you just don't have enough machine
learning or you know data engineering
devops skill sets to do as much as what
you actually want to do uh and then
oftentimes the data itself so you might
have the best idea the skills to support
it but you don't actually have all those
data sources in a consumable format you
know standardized together you don't
have a single game review for example to
actually start using it then it's really
difficult to deploy these kinds of
models and then you know when you get to
that point and you're you're seeing you
know really good business success you've
seen the ROI on your investment you can
be a victim of your own success wherein
you're like great now everyone wants a
data science model how do we move faster
and that's where things like the
infrastructure that you're using manage
services for things like model
monitoring endpoints you know training
and serving pipelines start to give you
that ability to scale you know 10x
faster rather than okay we're gonna have
to hire 10 more data scientists in order
to be able to scale you know for what we
need to do
the um so this sort of where we think
Google Cloud adds a lot of value in this
area and what we're really excited about
as a team to start integrating into the
stack that John actually just took you
through is vertex AI which is our
managed machine learning lifecycle
platform so you can do everything from
building your models right so whether
you want to do custom coding yourself
use like an automl talk about automl in
a minute all the way through to you know
what you actually need to keep the
lights on for that model in production
the
um you don't really have to use all
these Services you can pick and choose
which ones you want but for this team
what we're really focusing in on is how
can we move faster by using the managed
versions of everything that we want to
do so how do we create templates of the
pipelines for similar types of use cases
so that we can recycle that code and
we're not recreating the wheel every
single time we want to put a model into
production how do we use things like
automated model monitoring to just have
it run the training serving SKU
detection for us rather than us writing
those tests again and again every single
time this is where I think data science
teams are going to be able to move even
faster
so one of the first use cases that I
want to talk about is the sort of I'd
say the next evolution of the
reinforcement used learning use case
that you just heard tatsuo talk about in
terms of that online learning system
whereby it's not just a static model
it's actually learning from how people
interact with the emails that they're
opening so if you think about these
types of systems there are a few
challenges with them that actually
aren't just about building the model
itself which are actually really about
how do you maintain that entire system
for the model right because people are
going to change how they interact you're
not just going to send the same email
right to people over and over again
you're gonna you might change the time
of the day that you send the email you
might change the messaging that you send
in that email so you want to have an
agent that's able to learn on the fly
but then also simultaneously give you
the ability to retrain when you need to
when the world has changed because we
want to keep the content as relevant as
possible nobody wants to get spam emails
right that are totally useless to them
so so you know we're gonna be
implementing an approach using the
automl functionality within vertex and
we this is going to be very powerful in
the sense that divs gives us the ability
to take advantage of that neural
architecture search that's happening you
see all those crazy squiggles over there
that's that's searching through a lot of
different types of model architectures
to determine you know what is the best
model for this use case given what I
might already know like the context the
training data that I have this gives us
the ability to start to tap into things
like neural network architectures
boosted tree architectures without
having to write tons of code for that
every single time then because we'll
build an in vertex we can then integrate
it into a Vertex pipeline seamlessly so
that it's not just going to be we have
to build this model from scratch and the
whole system for every single deployment
like every game or every type of agent
we can now start to recycle the template
that we've built so that we can you know
roll this out much more broadly much
more quickly so you know you're taking
your deployment time from you you know
maybe two to three months down to like
days or maybe a week or something like
that so it's quite powerful in that
sense
um and then the sort of I think other
use case that
um we're really excited about is really
to leverage the functionality within
vertex around the endpoints for online
serving so from online serving
perspective this really refers to
um basically making the you know
prediction capabilities from a model
constantly available so you want this to
just be available as a service that you
can ping and get an output from sort of
any time as well as if there's certain
periods where you have a lot of traffic
or a lot of things happening the ability
for that produce prediction request to
be able to scale up or down as needed so
things don't just fall over right so you
know a common challenge uh I would say
you know thinking about the industry is
the sort of the separation in terms of
the back end Frameworks between you know
how games may be built versus how data
science teams tend to work historically
so you might have you know a back end in
C sharp or something like that too but
then you have you know all these models
from a data science perspective that
have been built in like python or maybe
you're using
um you know r or something like that or
bits of SQL here and there so how do we
close the gap between not necessarily
putting more engineering effort on the
separate teams to try to do something
that they wouldn't normally do but then
also get them to work more closely
together and take advantage of basically
you know the skills and the services
that both provide so you on vertex you
can take a model package it up create
your serving container and then put it
onto an endpoint so that it can just
basically pack be packaged up as you
know an https service really so you're
just sort of pinging it and you're
getting a Json response back this is
where we think we're gonna really start
to close the gap in terms of being able
to test more models more quickly so this
allows us to really quickly prototype
different use cases experiment more
quickly see what works as well as sort
of you know be able to keep the
responsibilities of the game team but
the game and then also the sort of
ownership of that model knowing when to
retrain the model when to test a new
version of the model can stay with the
data science team so they don't also
necessarily have to change their way of
working from an mlops perspective of how
they would put that model into
production for example so this I think
is a really exciting way that we can
start to bring real time like AI model
prediction service requests into the
games without having to really change
very much in terms of like architecture
skill sets what people are actually
working on uh so once again let us
accelerate and do more
uh yeah so I think we're just up at time
now uh thank you very much for coming to
the talk we will be around I think we
have a minute or two maybe for questions
uh yeah so yeah we can talk lots and
questions but thanks very much come to
find us talk to us
foreign